a drift star shailene woodley and sam
claflin and is based on a true story of
a couple that are stranded at sea when a
hurricane devastates their ship this
film explores how they met the
friendships they had and their tale of
survival during a devastating hurricane
movies where characters are stranded at
sea for the majority faced a lot of
challenges we can't go to a lot of
locations we all sort of know the plot
points that are usually explored
throughout these types of films a
shortage of food no water hallucinations
all of these things are explored in a
drift and it can sometimes feel a little
familiar but what keeps the movie afloat
haha float is shailene woodley who gives
a terrific performance filled with a lot
of depth there are some scenes that
really call on her to dig deep in
regards to trauma and feeling pain and
scenes where she feels like for sure
like we're going to die I know for a
fact we're going to die and she really
has to go to some really dark places she
pulls it off she is easily the best part
of this entire film her chemistry with
sam claflin however not as good this is
integral to the film we're supposed to
care about this couple we're supposed to
understand their plight and when they're
both in danger were supposed to care and
I just really didn't and one of the
biggest issues is the film's structure
this film juices to open after the
disaster happens so from the very
beginning we see shailene woodley
struggling to survive with sam claflin
and then we cut back to the past and we
see how they met and the film does that
throughout the entire runtime we go from
the disaster to the past and eventually
the two storylines meet this diffuses
almost all tension that's set up in the
survival scenes because we'll see a few
minutes of riveting stuff and then we
cut back to them having wine with random
people on a boat somewhere when they
were meeting each other's friends and
this just takes any tension or suspense
that was set up in the survival sequence
and it just plummets it and these past
sequences are mostly a lot of familiar
scenes where we get
to know them and they tell each other
stories about their lives and it doesn't
feel very romantic because I never for a
second bought in particular that Sam
clapping really cared all that much
about shailene Woodley's character
Woodley was really giving it her all and
I just wasn't feeling that same emotion
out of Sam clapping in the film it was
like she was really there and she was
really present and his character it's
not just the character that's reserved
it felt like the performer was as well
like he was just ready for them to call
cut so he could go home because he
didn't want to be there and that's what
it felt like in every scene Robert
Richardson was the director of
photography he primarily works with
Quentin Tarantino and so expect a really
great looking movie especially the
underwater stuff all of it looks amazing
but the main issues I kept going back to
were the structure the past sequences
mixed with a survival in the present it
just made it so all the tension is
diffused whenever we cut back to the
past and those sequences just felt very
rote and familiar and sam claflin was
not giving the same type of performance
that Woodley was she really seemed like
she was giving it her all and he seemed
like he was in different film I feel
like this movie will please most it is a
story that deserves to be told the
real-life woman and man at the center of
this story it's very nice to see their
story honored it's just that this film
didn't really justify its existence
beyond hey we have an interesting
backstory and this happened so let's put
it on screen because survival is awesome
and inspiration and everything but the
film really failed to thrill me at
almost every turn I'm gonna give adrift
a/c guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to a podcast
preview pretty soon of my podcast that I
host with my friend John Flickinger over
on patreon I'd say like once a month
I'll post like a little segment of it
just so you guys can enjoy it and see
what we're doing over there guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
look forward to more reviews very soon
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]